Alone. Mysterious texts teases your
curiosity. You're in a dark room.
Let's say an amusing basement.
No, even better. Some were
more adventurous. A cave.
Yeah.
Your excitement fades to baffled.
Wonder as your brain starts to hum
with the tedium of cracking this text,
a tedium that call's not for the brazen
and venturing of an Indiana Jones,
but the careful testing of a
touring or sample, you don't.
You don't know the language of this text.
You don't even know what words it encodes.
You can't even start to pronounce it.
Symbols. You're not even sure this is
writing at this moment of confusion.
If your ear is free, fellow language
traveler and budding decipher.
Let me hold out my hand
and offer a morsel of hope.
What if I told you that you can know what
these symbols are without ever needing
to know how to read them?
And what if I also told you all you
needed to do this was to know how to count
first pluck out the basic writing
types you met in thoughts pill. What?
You haven't seen that? No Way. Come on,
let's go watch it first and then come
back and pluck out the basic writing types
you met in thoughts, pill, consonant,
or vowel symbols, syllable symbols,
and words. Symbols. Now
let's start counting.
Take a string in English,
just a bit of written text and count the
number of distinct graphings you find
it. Okay, but longer is better here.
More chances for all the signs
and the writing system to show up,
including those less common ones.
You know your Qs, your ex's jerseys.
So let's count the signs in
all of Shakespeare's sonnets.
I'm counting everything but x.
So keep taking more and more bigger
and bigger samples in English.
And you'll end up counting the
26 letters of our alphabet.
Do the same for Russian.
And I hear you.
Account 33 try it with Hawaiian and you
only find 13 now reach for Japanese text
written entirely in syllables.
You'll count 46 Hiragana
Cherokee has 85 the syllables.
Wow. Now here's a jump up to
Hittite with over 500 symbols. Maya,
with more than 800 and Chinese
with thousands upon thousands.
So we ended up with alphabets on one end,
silver berries in the middle
end logo graphic or logo,
phonetic scripts on the far side.
But now you're facing a new script,
totally unknown to you, and you
count the symbols. It has hundreds.
What kind of script do you think it is?
What if it has 20 what if it has 50 or
60 we're using this simple algorithm to
make an educated guess
about an unknown script.
Ms Things referenced conceptually
and papers about decipherment,
but I don't know what it's called.
Robinson points us back to Archibald.
Say someone who loved himself, some a
Syrian. So do we call it the safe test?
The Archibald heuristic pulling
a space? Yeah. Pulling a sakes.
Pulling US space does come with
challenges and drawbacks to first,
there's the problem that you
still can't read the text. True,
but before you take all of
the wind out of my sails,
please celebrate what this
handy tool can do for you.
Second scripts can emphasize things,
but they're not really purely
phonetic or pure loga graphs. I mean,
think of the mix of letters and numbers,
punctuation,
and even idiot graphs you find all
around you and that's just an English.
Perhaps the biggest problem is
how do identify distinct symbols?
If you were trying to
decipher the Latin alphabet,
could you tell that all of
these are the same symbol? How?
What about capital letters
and lowercase letters?
Our accent marks distinct letters.
How do we count ligatures linked,
scripted together,
mashed together characters
or the component consonant
vowel pieces of a single
index syllable or the sound plus meaning
pieces inside of a single Chinese
character.
We have explanations for these and maybe
they're good enough for the scripts we
already know,
but what about trying to read an
undecipherable script like real no Romo?
Are these strange people looking things
to flipped a variance of a single sign
or are they two different sites?
True.
I admitted this little algorithm
doesn't pull us out of the dark,
but it gives us a starting point.
We can identify script types.
We can list symbols.
We can then use these lists to identify
the symbols when they show up in other
texts with a smile on our face.
Because even though this
script is still unknown to us,
we've devised a clever way to reach
a strange familiarity with it.
A big step on our way to decipher it.
I took a little time to play around with
and put together some simple code that
runs this test on any
piece of texts you give it.
It counts the number of different
symbols that are in that text.
Then uses those cutoff
numbers from earlier to guess
what kind of writing system
this is.
Yeah,
so let's try it for English,
the English alphabet.
Here's the 26 English letters.
We'll pass it down through
here and run this thing.
It tells us that English is an alphabet
who'd have thought. Same thing,
but with some random sentences.
Still an alphabet.
Let's go for here.
A gun at down here,
run it and it's syllables.
What about Hawaiian?
If you two have ever shared the
misfortune of leaving Hawaii,
you may have heard this
and it's in an alphabet,
and then there's Kanji. Oh yes. Oh,
whole list of them and their words,
symbols.
Well, that's super nerdy, but thanks for
letting me play with language a bit here.
It's kind of Nice doing more
off the cuff video like this.
It's a thing right off the cuff. It's
sounded wrong for some reason. Well,
leave comments and subscribe and encourage
me to come back again. Okay, bye.